all the masks are coming off in the
mainstream media bill de blasio
continues to posture as his citizens die
and the supreme court rules against
president trump on his tax returns i'm
ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
today's ben shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn your online activity
should not be public protect yourself at
expressvpn.com
ben alrighty so let's begin today with a
simple fact
the masks are off in the media there are
no more masks all the masks are gone
because president trump has basically
unmasked the media now everybody on the
right has been complaining for literally
decades that the media are biased
because the media
are biased and their bias has been
obvious and clear and this does go back
all the way to walter cronkite declaring
the ted offensive was a massive loss for
the united states
but despite the fact that the united
states actually crippled the north
vietnamese
militarily during the tower offensive
the media have long had
a liberal bias but now the masks are
completely off
and members of the media are making it
absolutely clear that the masks are
completely off and this holds in
virtually every area of american life
it's truly incredible i've never seen
media coverage this bad and it was
really bad during 2016 and it was really
bad in 2017 when all we got
wall-to-wall for two years was russian
collusion scandal stuff right
now it's as though the media have just
decided you know what we hate trump so
much
we hate people on the conservative side
so much we are just going to manipulate
data and lie with the data and just lie
with abandon it's really
truly incredible and this holds on every
topic it holds from
race relations in the united states to
the economy it holds from
covet 19 to everything that is
constitution and history related like
the media will just lie to you and then
they'll proclaim in journalism right the
1619 project
we put out there as journalism when it
is nothing but propaganda
and narratives will be promulgated about
how america is a deeply systemically
evil terrible racist place even when the
evidence for that is incredibly scanty
the media have an agenda and they are
making that agenda clear every single
day it's incredible it's on every topic
let me take a topic that really should
not be political for example
let me take the topic of what's going on
with covenant 19. so right now there's a
big spike
in the number of cases that we have seen
in places like texas arizona
california right we've seen these big
spikes
really across the southwest and then in
florida as well
we've seen some spikes in georgia too
it's an increase in caseload
now normally when you are examining what
exactly is the factor leading to the
spiking case load
what you might want to do is actually
correlate the data so for example
if you are seeing a big spike in case
load and it is coming eight to ten weeks
after the reopening maybe just maybe
it's not the reopening that is causing
this
maybe just maybe the most significant
factor you might posit
might be something like are people
spending lots of time endorsing their
conditioning did it get so hot down
south that everybody went in their
houses or went out to public places went
to restaurants and instead of eating
outdoors
they ate indoors instead of hanging out
with their friends on the beach it was
too hot they went inside and they hung
out at a bar right wouldn't that be
a factor that you would spend more time
on and in fact the data tends to support
this suggestion because
if you actually look at many of the
states that reopened
at the same time for example colorado
and georgia they've had wildly variant
caseloads so colorado
reopened literally the same day i
believe the same week for sure
as georgia and got no attention for it
because of course the governor of
colorado is a democrat and the governor
of georgia
is a republican and so georgia was going
to be the place where everyone dies
right everyone's going to die in georgia
and colorado
doesn't exist right it stopped existing
the minute that they did the same thing
as georgia well georgia
since the since the reopening it has now
been nearly three months since the
reopening in georgia according to the
new york times
they have started to experience an
uptick in cases right they're about 245
percent in cases which is a significant
uptick
in the number of cases and they're
starting to see more people hospitalized
and more people
are going to icu's now is it an
incredibly massive number of people who
are doing this
it's not it's not thousands of people
it's not several hundred people who are
dying in icu's
in georgia right now the deontay death
toll in georgia is still below 100 last
time i checked
okay but with all of that said they are
seeing a spike
but you know who's not seeing a spike
and opened at the exact same time
as colorado right colorado is not seeing
a spike colorado is down
41 according to the new york times in
average daily cases
so what the hell is going on and we
don't know what the hell is going on
the answer is probably the colorado in
the summertime is quite nice
and georgia in the summertime is
sweltering and so people in georgia are
going indoors and they are hanging out
in crowded places
indoors with lots of air conditioning
that is the most likely scenario here
that is that is the probable rationale
for why we are seeing
all of this happening is it or at least
it's a much better rationale than the
reopening because the reopening
really does not in any way reflect
the the sort of delayed statistics that
we are currently seeing by the way the
actual statistic on daily new deaths in
georgia
not only well below 100 well well below
100 like below 30.
daily deaths in georgia all of last week
i think yesterday it was
it was eight the day before that it was
23 according to worldometers
and so this mass spike that you're
seeing in cases is not correlated with
mass deaths in georgia you're seeing
increased deaths more so
not in georgia more so in in florida
more so
in texas more so in california where
you're seeing over 100 daily deaths
in places like that so is it the
reopening according to the media it is
the reopening
and this is where you see the mask
absolutely coming off so the the new
york times ramp is called the us surge
is being driven largely by states that
move to reopen early
and then they have a chart and it shows
places like florida arizona
south carolina texas georgia highlighted
on this chart right
because those are all the places that
reopened early a few places that are not
highlighted on the chart are places like
california that has also seen
a spike in fact a spike that is
similarly sized to georgia's but they're
not highly
why aren't they highlighted the reason
they're not highlighted because la
didn't really reopen la never reopened
right california
has not been reopened very long at all
and they are seeing a spike
as big as george does after a shorter
period of time so it doesn't it doesn't
help the narrative the media are trying
to push
that it's the evil republican states
that are causing all of this and the way
that you know
how corrupt the media are on all of this
is that the same chart from the new york
times
highlights new york so it shows florida
plus one thousand three hundred ninety
three percent in daily
hospital in daily cases in daily
identified cases
arizona up 858 in daily identified cases
by the way
largely in border areas there is a
serious issue with people who are coming
across the border specifically to go to
american hospitals because the hot
because the
the infection rate in mexico right now
is extraordinarily high and then
it shows new york new york down 52 what
did they do right
what could new york have possibly done
right okay the actual answer what's in
new york do right
everyone died that's the actual answer
okay the the reason
that it's incredible to watch the media
retcon this whole thing in real time
it's unbelievable actually i mean like
there was a tweet that was put out
scott gottlieb who's been a guest on my
sunday special he suggested the us
approach on covet is a tale of two
cities
some states like connecticut new york
massachusetts sought to crush the virus
some like florida texas and arizona
sought the swedish model and tried to
manage spreads of the less vulnerable
without a more uniform u.s approach
it'll be hard for either strategy to
work okay from just that tweet
you would think that there were some
states that attempted to crush the virus
and there were some states that sought
to manage the spread and they've ended
up kind of roughly equivalent or
something like that
right or even at the ones that are
crushing the virus there now they're
crushing the virus man
they've made it they've crushed the
virus and what actually happened
in northeastern states like new york
massachusetts connecticut new jersey the
ones that went into full lockdown mode
everyone died okay not because of the
lockdowns but because
it was there early they didn't know what
to do with it they were sending coveted
patients back into nursing homes
like half the patients who died in these
cases were nursing home
patients basically people who are in
elderly or assisted living facilities
hey let me give you the actual stats on
the quote unquote crush the curve
people versus the maintain the spread
people because right now remember
all focus in the united states is on
texas florida arizona right that's where
all the focus is right now
all of it okay it is not like there is
some focus
on new jersey or new york or by the way
cases continue to crop up in new york
there's still 500 to a thousand daily
cases
in new york that are happening every
single day and if you look
at these states where there's still mass
levels of death
just gonna note new york still ranks
like numbers
number six on this chart new jersey had
over 100 deaths yesterday
is anyone talking about new jersey in
order of in order of
deaths yesterday it goes california
number one california had 137
no one's mentioned in california florida
number two it's according to world
nominees
new jersey is number three so two of the
top three are blue states right
but you don't hear california and you
don't hear new jersey new jersey had
over a hundred deaths yesterday
texas is number four behind new jersey
at 102 arizona's number five
at 75 then new york at 32 and virginia
which is now blue
at 32 and pennsylvania which is now blue
at 31
right then you've got massachusetts
which is blue at 25. okay then you get
down into tennessee north carolina south
carolina
okay so that list does not suggest that
red versus blue is the deciding factor
here right you're seeing it in red
states and you're seeing in blue states
you're seeing it in lockdown states and
you're seeing it in non-lockdown states
what does this actually suggest
it suggests that when the virus goes
around it kills everybody who's
vulnerable
and the only thing you can really do is
protect the vulnerable that's really
what it suggests
and the less time you can spend in
confined areas with people breathing
from the same air conditioning
facilities
the better you off you are that's all
this suggests it doesn't suggest even
that masking is the particularly
effective factor
right maybe masking works maybe it
doesn't maybe it slows the spread maybe
the evidence on this is actually kind of
mixed okay
by the way the going medical wisdom up
until 2016 2017
is that wearing masks to prevent the
spread of flu for example
was not supremely effective so there's
some evidence that suggests
sure it helps stop the spread of this
thing particularly if you're in close
quarters
for not huge periods of time but it is
also true that a lot of the particles do
escape the mask and all the rest of this
sort of stuff so
i think that clarity here in what we
don't know
is actually quite useful but the media
are attempting to drive a narrative and
so the media are just being dishonest
about all of this stuff
right the suggestion that lockdowns are
the key and then we should re-lock down
because lockdowns are the key
is absolutely anti-data okay there is
not
enough data to support this perspective
let me give you the total deaths by
state
okay total deaths by state because
remember we're told that some of these
states
texas florida arizona you're doing it
wrong you opened up too early
georgia you did it you opened up too
early new york new jersey massachusetts
connected you locked it down guys
you were really solid on this stuff wait
until you hear the differential in
deaths in these states
okay because what that would suggest is
i'm kind of not okay let me explain in
just one second first
let us talk about the fact that solid
personal finance right now it has never
been more important the economy is an
absolute flux maybe it's in shambles
maybe it's in recovery who the hell
knows but the bottom line is you must be
on top of your own personal finances at
this point in time
don't let your personal finances get you
down simplify by quicken is here to help
you can start healthier financial habits
and achieve your long-term goals with
simplify by quicken
simplify makes it easy to see the big
picture stay on top of your spending and
save like a pro
say goodbye to surprise charges from
subscriptions you forgot you signed up
for simplify by quicken
makes it easy to monitor all your
spending so you're never in the dark
you're right on top of your own data
in granular fashion other financial apps
primarily track what's already happened
in the past
but simplify helps you plan for the
future and get personalized tips and
insights to help develop healthy
long-term habits and stay on top of your
finances
now and forever start your free 30-day
trial of simplify today when you
download our app or visit
simplifymoney.com
shapiro that's s-i-n-p-l-i-f-i
money dot com shapiro simplify with an i
at the end
money.com shapiro to start your free
30-day trial of simplify today and get
control
of your personal finances technology can
help you out in a time like this go
check out simplifymoney and i at the end
simplifymoney.com should be up for the
free
30-day 30-day trial when you download
the app okay so
here are the actual death statistics
from each of these states because
remember
the narrative the media is that was the
new york times headline not my headline
new york times headline current spike
being driven by states that reopen it's
the lockdowns that caused all of this
right the end of the lockdowns is what
has caused all this never mind the fact
that the media were literally cheering
on mass protests in the streets
in state after state across the country
among young people and then
surprise surprise a bunch of young
people ended up sick with coven who
could have predicted such a thing
who could except for everyone with half
a working brain but
again that that started by the media are
trying to drop between good blue states
good
excellent blue states and bad evil
anti-lockdown red states where they
don't believe in science
okay let me give you the actual deaths
for state and then i'll give you the
population adjusted deaths per million
okay deaths
by state new york 32 343
they have a population of 19.5 million
new jersey
15 522 total population of new jersey
8.9 million massachusetts 8 268.
total population 6.9 million connecticut
348 total population 3.5 million okay so
some of those states you haven't even
heard about right you've heard a lot
about new york and new jersey because
those were the big headlines
who knew that massachusetts had had over
8 000 deaths
8 000 that's a lot of deaths guys okay
who knew the connecticut
which is a tiny postage stamp of a state
gorgeous state but only 3.5 million
people lived there had had over 4 000
deaths
who knew that that's a big number for a
very small state
now here by contrast are your evil
terrible no-good
very bad la anti-lockdown states you
ready texas
with a total population of 29 million 10
million higher than new york
right it has the population of new york
and new jersey combined
does texas has a bigger population than
new york and new jersey combined
remember new york and new jersey
have had a combined total of nearly at
this point approaching 50 000 deaths
in those two states texas with the total
population of 29 million
is at 3046 deaths as of today
florida with a total population of 21.5
million which is again
2 million higher than new york state has
about 4 000 deaths
right now arizona which has 7.3 million
citizens which is a population slightly
larger than that of massachusetts by
about four hundred thousand
has two thousand dots okay so who
crushed what curve now
who's done like a great job here's a
quick list of the deaths per million
by those populations okay new york new
jersey massachusetts connecticut and the
one group
and then texas florida arizona and the
other group right because we're we're
now
following the media's narrative the
media's narrative is that the second
group is the evil group
the second group did it wrong they
didn't lock down long enough and maybe
we need to go back to lockdown
because lockdown is the key right okay
here are the
deaths per million population by state
new york
1663 new jersey 1748
massachusetts 1200 connecticut 1200
texas 105 florida
187 arizona 280.
so in other words the lock down lock it
all down we're going to crush the curve
flatten the curved states
have a death rate per million that is
somewhere between 8 and 15 times as high
as the evil no good very bad texas
florida arizona states
okay so maybe that's going to change
maybe that'll change right we don't know
we don't maybe this is a time lag maybe
the reality is that as the summer goes
on
many more people will die in texas
florida and arizona what is one thing
you certainly cannot justify at this
point you cannot justify the argument
that lockdowns themselves
were the key to answering this question
because they clearly weren't in new york
new jersey massachusetts and connecticut
they clearly were not a far more
plausible theory is that the population
was subjected to the virus at mass
numbers and a lot of people died
and now the r naught has basically
declined because
now they're not enough people to infect
other people because once a significant
percentage of your population's already
had this thing
well then you've reached some level of
quasi-herd immunity at least you've
slowed the spread there's two ways to
slow the spread
right one is to prevent people from
getting the infection in the first place
the second is you take people off the
board
unfortunately tragically either many
people died from this thing
or they were infected and then they and
then they recovered right and now they
can't pass the thing
but the media are so invested in the
narrative that they are willing to sell
you a basic lie
and that's incredible that's incredible
and again the basic lie is driven in
pursuit of a broader
agenda and that broader agenda is we got
to keep everything shut down everything
has to be shut down and if you mention
that the schools you might want to open
them
if you suggest that companies should
remain open
well then you're the bad guy now let's
be real about this
at no point along this entire way
is anyone in the media being honest with
you that there is no alternative
by which we all remain locked down until
a vaccine is available that is not an
alternative it is not a thing that is
going to happen it's not happening in
europe france has already announced
they're not going back into lockdown if
they go if they if they start to have
another uptick
they're not going back into lockdown
right they're just going to move with
mitigation canada
has basically suggested the same thing
the idea that everybody's going to go
back into lockdown until a
non-existent vaccine that may never
arrive properly is going to save us all
from the deus ex machina style like i
wish i wish you wish we all wish right
but that doesn't have anything to do
with reality the reality is we're all
going to have to learn
how we live with this thing and this
brings up the question of schools which
we're going to get to in just a second
okay again all of this tied into a
broader narrative about the media's
newfound honesty in their dishonesty
right now they're the
they're still it's amazing they're still
claiming objectivity at the same time
they're openly
promoting particular points of view like
openly not hiding it anymore
we're gonna get to more of this in just
one second first let's talk about if you
are web browsing without a vpn to
protect
yourself you're being a fool i know many
of you are thinking right now but i use
incognito america incognito mode doesn't
hide your activity
it doesn't matter what mode you use or
how many times you clear that browsing
history your isp can still see
every single website you've ever visited
which is why even when i'm at home i
never go online without using expressvpn
it doesn't matter if you get your
internet from verizon or comcast isps in
the united states
can legally sell your information to ad
companies expressvpn is an app that
reroutes your internet connection
through their secure servers so your isp
can't see the sites you visit
expressvpn also keeps all your
information secure by encrypting 100 of
your data with the most powerful
encryption available
most of the time i don't even realize i
have expressvpn on it runs seamlessly in
the background it's easy to use
all you have to do is tap one button and
you are now protected expressvpn is
available on all your devices phones
computers even your smart tv so there
really is no excuse for you not to be
using it
it's always a good idea to protect
yourself from bad actors hackers people
who want your data your information
protect your online activity today with
the vpn rated number one by cnet and
wired visit my exclusive link
expressvpn.com
you can get an extra three months for
free on a one-year package that's
e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com
expressvpn.com to learn more go check
them out
right now okay so the media's narrative
on a lot of the stuff is is obviously
driven by
politics more than it is driven by data
the reality is
that hospitals are indeed seeing an
increased burden we are not seeing the
hospitals being overloaded
even in new york by the way where it got
really close to being overloaded they
were actually not overloaded with
coveted right a lot of the facilities
ended up going empty the new facilities
that were built
one houston er doctor right things are
bad in houston one houston er doctor
said you know you guys really stop need
to
making you need to stop making the
comparison to new york because
new york right we are seeing uptick in
cases and we are seeing an uptick in
hospitalizations
but we have resources this is not new
york
i think everybody's worried about you
know the continued
escalating cases and what happens then
but today
we are we are full but we are we are
making new beds and we are pulling more
people into work and staff those beds
so that's where we're at it's certainly
not
as bad as it was in new york city and my
colleagues there
went through it's horrifying what they
went through we are we are not at that
point
um that being said everybody wants to
prevent us from getting to that point so
we're also asking everyone to please
stay at home
possible and wear a mask okay so again
the
the the notion that we should be worried
is correct notion that we are about to
be overwhelmed new york style
and remember the goal of flattening the
curve for the one millionth time was
never to prevent the spread
okay the the goal of flattening the
curve was to prevent the system from
being overwhelmed we are not seeing that
right now okay so this has also opened
up
a whole conversation about whether we
should reopen the schools
now what the data suggests is that kids
are not getting this particularly young
kids
young kids if you're under the age of 20
the statistics suggest
you're more at risk from the flu than
you are from this it is less deadly to
kids under the age of 20 to young people
than the flu okay we don't cancel school
because of the flu
we don't like on rare occasions i have
seen stories about schools being
cancelled because of the flu that is a
very
very rare circumstance what people are
really worried about are the teachers
right they're really worried that the
teachers are going to come in and you've
got a 50 year old math teacher gets
infected with coveted and dies from from
one of the students
and that's a legit worry right it's
legit to worry about the teachers
but we have this bizarre situation where
now everybody is staying at home
but kids are going out and playing with
their friends many of them going to
summer camp
and then you basically have de facto
school
right you have de facto kids getting
together with counselors
and then they come home and their
parents are older like
in other words a lot of this doesn't
make any sense so president trump has
said listen we should open the schools
what we are seeing right now with vast
numbers of kids
like literally 40 of kids apparently in
in los
angeles never even did one zoom session
in school
during the last school year so when
things shut down they just were like
okay well i guess it's summer
it was the middle of march right so the
the idea that we're gonna have an entire
another school year where people are
going to school for two days a week
where four-year-olds are socially
distancing and this kind of thing like
that that is really not a possibility
and there have been some columnists in
the new york times who are not of the
right saying
listen what are you gonna do for like
single moms who have to work
right they have to work what's your plan
here because you're basically suggesting
that they have no child care remember
school isn't just a place where kids
learn it is also a place where parents
drop off their kids
and then go to work so what exactly
happens here so it seems like schooling
is kind of vital
and it also seems like one of the only
things we know about this disease
is that it does not strike kids thank
god thank god right that it's one of the
only things we know which would suggest
that maybe some creative solutions could
be in the offing so for example
why not have schools my my friend john
pat horts on the commentary podcast
magazine which is definitely worth the
subscription
you should go listen to it john potter
horse has made the suggestion i think
it's a smart suggestion
why not have schools where kids go to
school and you have 21 year olds
out of college proctors basically and
then the teacher
zooms in why is it the teacher has to
zoom in to all their kids in their own
homes
why not let the kids go to school right
then you have
sort of the best of both worlds and you
have younger teachers who are there
who are likely not going to be infected
with this in a very serious way right
you have a bunch if you're 21 or 22
you're not dying from this thing
on a statistical level they're very some
people will die that's a real
real real exception statistically
speaking and why isn't that on the table
but the idea is if you even mention
opening schools it's because you don't
care about the children well
but kids aren't dying from this what the
hell are you talking about what you're
really talking about is protecting the
teachers okay fair enough but you don't
shut down the schools to protect the
teachers
right if the education is for the
students what you do is you make sure
that the students can go to school
and then you let the teachers skype in
and why is this off the table
so trump mentions this and all hell
breaks loose we have to open
our schools open our schools
stop this nonsense we open our schools
germany norway so many countries right
now
they're open the schools are open and
they're doing just fine and they're
opening in the fall
so we have to get our schools open
denmark
sweden we have to get our schools
open okay so people are saying yeah but
all those places have this thing under
control and that's true
that's true it makes things a lot easier
when you don't have a large
baseline of cases right that's true but
it is also true
that the rate of kids dying from this
thing is the same across the world right
and that is extraordinarily
extraordinarily low so
then you have nancy pelosi just
demagoguing this thing right nancy
pelosi says we don't want our children
risking school
the kids aren't at risk okay they're the
only subgroup of the population who are
at lower risk for this thing
than than they are of the flu but here's
an answer i mean
this is just lying with with not even
real statistics with fake statistics
secretary of education
indicated that children should go to
school they have to take risks
everybody takes risk take risk to ride a
bicycle to be an astronaut
there's risk you have to take risk no we
don't want our children to take risk
to go to school we're supposed to
mitigate
for any damage we're supposed to keep
them safe
so with stiff competition that was one
of the most ill-informed
statements stiff competition though in
this administration
on this and other subjects okay that's
absurd okay
the risk to kids from going to school
from this thing is lower than the risks
of the kids going to school
with the flu out and about right and so
she's just lying about this sort of
stuff but this has become again
the conventional wisdom is in the media
how dare we discuss
going to school again like two weeks ago
again half the left was like kids need
to go to school so parents can go to
work
because what do we do with all the
single moms we need to work
and now it's like nancy pelosi is out
there the kids aren't the kids are not
at risk like that's the only thing we do
know
that's like we know very little about
this virus that is literally one of the
only things we know
can we get into more of the media just
stripping off the mask it's incredible
it's incredible to watch in real time as
the media just strips off the mask
it's particularly front issues of race
we'll get to that in a second first
right now terrible time to go to the
post office like really bad time to go
to the post office
and stand in line in an air conditioned
facility with other people
carrying packages sounds terrible so
what should you be doing the same thing
you always should have been doing you
should be using
our friends over at stamps.com with
stamps.com you can print postage onto
man skip those lines and crowds of the
post office the post office does a lot
of great stuff but why not just do that
stuff
directly from home stamps.com offers ups
services too with discounts up to 62
and no ups residential surcharges here
at dailywear we've used stamps.com since
2017.
no more wasting our time stamps.com
brings all the services of the us postal
service directly to your computer in the
safety and comfort of your own home
office or anywhere else you're hunkering
down right now whether you're a small
business sending invoices or an online
seller shipping out products or you're
just working from home and you need to
mail stuff
stamps.com can handle it all with ease
simply use your computer to print
official us postage 24 7
for any letter any package any class of
mail anywhere you want to send it
once your mail is ready just leave it
for your mail carrier schedule a free
package pick up or drop it in the
mailbox no human contact required it is
indeed
that simple and like i said with
stamps.com you get great discounts as
well five cents off every first class
stamp
up to 62 percent off shipping rates this
is a no-brainer and right now
my listeners get a special offer it
includes a four-week trial plus free
postage and digital scale no long-term
commitment just head on over to
stamps.com
click on the microphone at the top of
the homepage and type in shapiro at
stamps.com
enter a code shapirostamps.com enter
code shapiro okay so it's not just on
covet 19 where the media have been
doing yeoman's work on behalf of a
narrative that is unrelated to the
factual situation undergirding it
on race obviously media have been doing
the same thing in dramatic dramatic ways
it's a good article by my friend john
lott over in real clear politics
talking about the media divide on
reporting in race-based cases
he says on saturday a man drove his car
onto a seattle freeway that had been
closed by a black lives matter crowd
the driver killed one person and
seriously injured another after going
the wrong way up a ramp and then around
a barricade
reporters notes reports noted that the
police quote
don't believe impairment was a factor
over the weekend news outlets replayed
the brutal hit but here's one thing you
won't learn from their coverage
the driver was black his victims were
white npr linked this attack to other
car ramming incidents by quote
right-wing extremists targeting black
lives matter protesters
they quoted a researcher about how these
right-wingers were quote trying to
intimidate the most recent wave of blm
protesters to stop their movement
the driver was a seattle local named
wheat kilit but you'll find scant
mention of the driver's ethnicity in
mainstream at media coverage
you might have more easily learned that
he was black by going to australia's
broadcasting corporation
the american national media don't note
that keeley's two victims were white
you can only find that out over the uk
daily mail
one case doesn't prove a pattern it
could be that while the american media
knows almost everything about this
killer including his name age where he
lives they couldn't find information on
his race
but um probably not research conducted
by the crime prevention research center
of which i am president says john lott
on all police shootings from 2013 to
2015 found that while local news
coverage will often mention the race of
the officer and the suspect
the national coverage is much more
selective while the evidence indicates
that black officers are no less likely
to shoot suspects than white officers
local news coverage of black officers
shooting black suspects
gets picked up by the national news in
just nine percent of cases
by contrast 38 percent of the cases in
which
local news reported on a white officer
shooting a black suspect
get national coverage okay so in other
words they're only covering the story
when the story supports their broader
narrative
we've talked about this very often on on
the program and by the way we've put in
calls here at daily wedding we're
putting calls to places like the l.a
times and the new york times
looking for what is your objective
journalistic standard on when you
mention race
in a particular case right why is it
that you won't mention race if a black
person kills a white person but if a
white person kills a black person you'll
of the time mention the race it's not
just that the the stories that get
picked up at the national level
it's how the races are mentioned when
the stories are picked up at the
national level
as well this is not a shock
this is what the media do and then they
call it objective news coverage
now the most obvious about this sort of
stuff is don lemon so don lemon still
bizarrely claims that he's an objective
news reporter which is just
i mean you have to be an insane person
to believe this you have to have been
dropped on your head as a baby not one
time but like repeatedly and from
a great height and with force in order
to believe this contention
so here is don lemon explaining on
uprocks that he is not a biased reporter
he is just speaking his truth
which is the definition of bias okay
once you say it's my truth
and not the truth then you are no longer
an objective news reporter you're an
opinion person
and my truth is your subjective
perception of the world the truth is an
objectively verifiable description of a
situation
here is don lemon conflating the two and
then claiming that he's an objective
news reporter
my role as a journalist is to speak from
my truth and from my lens and from where
i come from
and i don't think those things are
biases i am a black man
who grew up and who lives and survives
and works in america
i have a certain perspective and a
certain point of view and i'm bringing
that
important part of the diverse um culture
of this company
to the fore and i should be and so the
people who don't want to hear that
they who don't want to hear my truth
will say to you
that i am biased i'm not biased this is
my truth
as a black man in america he's not
biased guys he's not biased at all this
is just his truth
which is bias the definition of bias
it's pretty incredible stuff right the
media's mass they're all coming off and
they don't even understand the masks are
slipping
right they keep going why are we losing
credibility because you keep
promulgating narratives that are not
true about the state of the united
states
because they are quote unquote your
truths and politicians pick up on this
by the way
right politicians pick up on all of this
and then they run with it
like the bill de blasio has picked up on
this and he's running with it
so people are getting shot like every
single day in new york they're seeing a
vast uptick in the murder rate in new
york city
virtual i believe last i checked 100 of
all people shot in new york city
over the course of the last month are
people of color nearly all of them are
black
that is not something bill de blasio
will talk about
instead bill de blasio will will simply
say that it's time to paint giant murals
that say black lives matter
in front of trump tower on fifth avenue
and what will the media cover
will the media cover this stuff no the
media the media won't cover the
shootings really
they'll cover it kind of tangentially
there's a headline yesterday i believe
is from the ap
talking about it's puzzling why the
shootings have increased
i think they use the word mysterious to
describe why the shootings have
increased
get the scooby van guys who the hell
knows get the mystery machine
we gotta we got to get shaggy on the
case all right who could
rut roll who could figure it out
why would there be more shootings when
you're trying to defund the police you
idiots
and when you're focusing on painting
giant yellow signs that say black lives
matter in front of trump tower ooh we
showed trump
orange man bad problem solved hey so
bill de blasio here he was painting
blm in front of the trump tower he said
this is an example of action we can take
for black americans
wow you well america's a better place
today because you painted some letters
on a sidewalk
boom done magical wow
the great irony is going to be and the
great horrible irony is going to be when
a person of color gets shot
and dies on the logo that says black
lives matter outside trump tower because
that's what's going to happen in new
york city eventually right i mean
that is the symbol of bill de blasio's
mayoralty
it's a giant strip painting that says
black lives matter and then people of
color
dying on it after being shot in his city
okay because that's what's actually
going on in his city here's bill de
blasio talking about all the wonderful
things he's done for black people like
putting paint on a sidewalk i mean like
great work there comey bill
it was that's an important message the
people of this city believe black lives
matter and we wanted to send that
message to our whole city but to our
whole nation
and it can't just be words wolf it has
to be actions so we're
taking resources from our police
department and putting into youth
programs
we're acknowledging institutional racism
and coming up with specific plans to
tear it down
we need to take this transcendent moment
and get the most out of it
oh man transcendent moment paint some
stuff let's paint
peace murals we've done it built wow
well i mean he's really he's really
committed to this thing it's it's
incredible
really really great and by the way then
trump came out and he was like this this
mural is stupid and
and black lives matter means more than
just the slogan the organization is
really radical and de blasio's like
ah well now i've trolled you i've
trolled you successfully
it's pure racism for trump to oppose the
mural okay
meanwhile meanwhile i'm just gonna point
out two nights ago
five people in his city were shot and
one person died that was two nights ago
i don't know the updates from last night
because the reporting hasn't come out
yet i'm sure more people were shot last
night
because that is the way that this is all
working bill de blasio by the way he
also says that in the middle of a
pandemic
he says he's not going to allow any
large gatherings except for blm
gathering i'm not kidding it's this
thing he said this is purely
unconstitutional by the way you cannot
do this
you cannot say only one type of protest
is so
important and so legit that they get to
hold it right
that's not the way the first amendment
works in the united states here's bill
de blasio comey bill
explaining things that here in the city
can mean
not just thousands tens of thousands
hundreds of thousands of people
it's just not time for that now what
about protests if people want to march
down
fifth avenue or they're gonna be allowed
to do so look wolfe this is always an
area of real sensitivity if you're just
talking about
health we would always say hey folks you
know stay home if you can but
we understand at this moment in history
people are talking about the need for
historic
changes i mean today in new york city
you know
recognizing the power and the meaning of
the message black lives matter which we
did in front of trump tower today
basically blitzer asked him so you're
going to allow these protests he's like
oh maybe
kinda he just said no large gatherings
shut down those hasidic
jews with their praying but black lives
matter
absolutely guys i mean this is just such
an important moment it's such an
important moment by the way this giant
important moment
has not prevented people from shooting
each other on mass in his city
the the new york the new york police
department is now begging cops
to delay retiring so cops are like i'm
not sticking around for this
are you crazy why would i possibly stick
around for this i've got the city that
will prosecute me for defending myself
i've got a city that will not allow me
to do my work with local communities
trying to protect innocent citizens you
think i'm sticking around for this bull
crap
according to a report by the new york
post 503 cops in new york city
have filed for retirement since may 25th
that was the day that george floyd
was killed okay that is a 75 increase a
near doubling
over the same period in 2019. the past
week
179 cops filed for retirement in one
compared to 35 in 2019 a 411
increase so the city is now begging
people
begging people not to leave so bill de
blasio the mayor of new york controls
the nypd
bill de blasio what has he been
relegated to at the same time people are
shooting each other on mass in his city
and he's painting murals on the sidewalk
here was bill de blasio's answer to how
do you stop violence
he's begging people please stop killing
each other i'm sure it's going to go
great bill i'm sure
again there are not they're not enough
slow claps on planet earth to provide
for this idiot giant weirdo
you can't just do it with police you
need community leaders clergy
community organizations to come together
we're having a particular issue in
harlem
and we've gathered community leaders
from all over harlem who in common cause
this weekend are gonna be out there with
the police
shoulder to shoulder saying we're not
gonna allow this violence in our
community
the second piece is to get our court
system up and running
it's been at a very low speed the
criminal justice system in this state is
not fully functioning
and that's creating a lot of problems
even when police arrest someone
the consequences aren't there oh you
mean like how your plan was to release
everybody without bail
like that that plan where you're taking
career criminals arresting them and just
releasing them without bail because bail
is racist or something
this guy this guy the media continue to
probably get the narrative that bill de
blasio is like a racial justice warrior
while black people are getting shot on
mass in his city it's unbelievable
it truly is incredible so listen
politicians respond to incentive
structures the media have created an
incentive structure
the media incentive structure is you
repeat the narrative that
we want you to repeat and we will bless
you we will bless you top down
you will always receive our love and if
you process we will break you on the
wheel of fire
if you're ron desantis or greg abbott if
you're doug ducey in arizona we'll break
you on the wheel of
fire but if you're bill de blasio you
can basically let a virus like kill
everyone in your city
and then the ones who are left you can
let them shoot each other and everyone
you know what as long as you made a
mural everything's good everything's
perfectly good
the media create the incentive structure
guys and that's why it kind of matters
when the media suck at their jobs
royally suck at their jobs and by the
way continue to promote
a canceled culture that expediently
exempts
those who are allied with it we'll get
to that in just one second
first let's talk about the fact that
right now bad time to go to an auto
parts store instead why not check out
rockauto.com it's a lot easier than
going to an auto parts store you're
going to save a lot of money over going
to an auto parts store
sometimes auto parts stores will
actually charge you differently based on
whether you're a professional or a
do-it-yourselfer
not at rockauto.com it's one low price
for everybody they charge much lower
prices than the big box stores you're
used to going to
rockauto.com always offers the lowest
prices possible rather than changing the
prices based on what the market will
bear
like airlines do rockauto.com is a
family business serving auto parts
customers online for 20 years go to
rockauto.com to shop for auto and body
parts from hundreds of manufacturers
best of all
prices at rockauto.com are always
reliably low and the same for
professionals and do-it-yourselfers why
spend up to twice as much for the same
parts the rockauto.com catalog is unique
remarkably easy to navigate
quickly see all the parts available for
your vehicle and choose the brands
specifications and prices you prefer
they've got amazing selection reliably
low prices all the parts your car will
ever need
rockauto.com go check them out right now
at rockauto.com see all the parts
available for your car
or truck and write shapiro in there how
did you hear about us box so they know
that we sent you that's rockauto.com
check them out right now and save
yourself time save yourself money and
get the best available
cards for your vehicle alrighty we're
gonna get to the
the mainstream media pushing forward the
cancel culture because this is the new
move is members of the media trying to
shut the door behind them only they can
be the greatest disseminators of
information
everybody else you shut up and we're
going to try and bully all the social
media companies into shutting the doors
to everyone except like the new york
times we'll get to that in just one
second first
it is that time of the week when i give
a shout out to a daily wire member
today it's jay light on twitter who
understands the importance of proper
early education in this picture collage
our four children of varying ages from
infant
to probably middle or early high school
all holding the world's greatest
beverage vessel
in one picture the two oldest girls gail
and brenna are holding
an american flag while wearing facts
don't care about your feelings t-shirts
and impressively balancing
two leftist tears tumblers each that's a
lot of leftist tears the caption reads
hey ben shapiro daniela and brena are
fans from arizona proud americans and
conservatives
they they thank you for everything you
do appreciate having you as a role model
and inspiration
and love their leftist tears tumbler all
four of them just awesome i do love
hearing that thanks for the picture
and thanks to yael and brena for their
support
also you should go pick up an early
early do it right now because
you don't want to run out of stock sign
copy of my new book how to destroy
america in three easy steps time grows
short we are 11 days from release how to
destroy america in three easy steps the
most important book you're gonna read
this year i really believe that
i think that right side of history was
deeply important i think how to destroy
america in three easy steps
is about what makes america worth saving
and what are the steps that are being
taken to destroy it
i wrote it months ago but it almost
reads like prophecy now frankly not to
tap myself too highly but
the reality is that i wrote about the
destruction of america's history
via the 1619 project and how it's going
to tear us apart the destruction of
america's philosophy of equal rights
before law
right pre-existing government government
answerable to the people how those
principles were under attack by a left
that only cares about power
and the and how the america's culture of
rights the way we discuss rights with
each other freedom of association
freedom of speech how that was all
disappearing in favor of the idea that
government can give you everything you
want if only you give them all the power
they need right these are the factors
and the disintegration of america
it really isn't about left versus right
it really is about people who want a set
of principles that can hold us all
together
versus people who wish to divide the
country and then have the slight
majority
beat the living hell out of the slight
minority right that is the that is the
goal politically for the
disintegrationists the book is called
how to destroy america in three easy
steps you can pre-order your signed copy
i'm signing them right now
at dailywire.com that's dailywire.com
you can even ask me a question with your
which with your purchase
that may be read during my live signing
events on the days of the book's release
so you'll enjoy that if you're not
already a daily remember by the way you
should also get a readers pass at
dailywire.com great value three bucks a
month when you sign up you get the first
month for just 99 cents you also get
access to our mobile app
articles ad free and access to exclusive
editorials like this
satire biden campaign proposes one
debate moderated by the daniers biden
calls nana
i can only imagine the clavin wrote that
so if you haven't checked out the
reader's pass already head on over to
dailywire.com
and sign up for just one dollar you're
listening to the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
[Music]
okay so the media and the left have
united in promoting cancel culture
obviously you're only canceled by the
way
if you are not a member of the canceled
culture so if you are a member of the
braying mob
you will never be cancelled right as
long as you pray along with the mob for
people's heads
you're fine perfect example joy reid
remember that time that joy reed had
like a bunch of really really bad old
tweets
remember then this is the game that we
play online as we find your bad old
tweets capital b
capital o capital t bad old tweets
trademark right that we find your battle
tweets we resurface them
and then we come after your career well
probably a year ago
a bunch of bad old joy retweets surfaced
like on race
and on and on homosexuality and they're
pretty yucky
right and joy reid promptly claimed that
she had been hacked retroactively
and marty mcfly got in his time machine
and went back to 2006
and hacked into joy reid's blog page and
put up all these old posts
somehow the blogger mysterious one-armed
blogger was never found
okay so it turns out that obviously that
doesn't exist she wrote this stuff but
she's not counseled joy reads she now
has a brand new
show on msnbc oh yeah
she has hosted the msnbc weekend talk
show am joy since 2016.
she's going to move to the 7 pm hour on
july 20th her show the readout
succeeds hardball and it says chris
matthews which is
sad i mean first of all i do miss my
chris matthews impersonation
you can just imagine him at home did i
read they threw me out for being a jerk
and please this lady on who has old
tweets talking about homophobia what the
hell happened here well
the answer here is that chris matthews
was out of step with the times but joy
reid
is a full-fledged member of the
committee on public safety over at msnbc
and she is willing to guillotine anyone
who disagrees
with the left politically speaking miss
reed's promotion says the new york times
is a significant programming move by
cesar conde the new chairman
of nbc's news network black women
including gayle king of cbs and robin
roberts of abc
hold leading roles in morning and
daytime television but none currently
host a nightly evening show on a major
network
the last to do so was gwen ifill who
co-anchored pbs newshour until shortly
before her death
in 2016. evening in prime time news has
been a universe of white
men really since i was growing up said
miss reed for somebody who grew up as a
nerdy kid obsessed with news
watching nightline and meet the press
the idea of being a part of that family
has always just been kind of
overwhelming well
you know good for her because now it
turns out the canceled culture
does not does not come after you if you
are a member
of the canceled culture the new york
times buries down in this piece that
reed apologized for writing mocking
claims that charlie crist former florida
governor was gay
but then there are additional posts or
she opened that most straight people
cringe at the sight of two men
kissing and a lot of heterosexuals
especially men find the idea of
homosexual sex to be gross
and she said rachel maddow held views
the most left-wing end of the political
spectrum
she claimed the post had been fabricated
she said i genuinely do not believe i
wrote those hateful things because they
are completely alien to me
the person i am now is not the person i
was in listen you can apologize for
stuff
right i mean that's okay apologizing for
stuff but not in cancel culture you
can't
unless you're a member of the canceled
culture in which case absolution is just
one
brutal beating of a third party around
the corner right if you want to absolve
yourself all you have to do is find
somebody
else to join in mobbing right if you
don't want to be mobbed all you have to
do is point to that guy over there and
then join the mob
pick up that pitchfork and you are good
to go which is exciting
stuff aoc by the way now pushing the
canceled culture pretty hard what's
amazing about aoc pushing the cancel
culture
is literally a year ago she was whining
about how she was being canceled by the
democratic brass
and there are members of the democratic
party who are like maybe we shouldn't
give money
to aoc's committees when she is trying
to primary sitting members of the
democratic party
and she was like this is mean this is
cruel and now she's like cancel culture
doesn't even exist
people who are actually canceled like
don't get their thoughts published and
amplified
in major outlets this has been a public
service announcement
okay well a lot of people who are
canceled don't get their thoughts
published and amplified to major outlets
in fact
i can think of somebody who is the
editor of the new york times op-ed page
who just got fired
for amplifying a message that the left
didn't like in the new york times op-ed
page
right that editor got fired for that she
said but it doesn't exist she says the
term cancel culture comes from
entitlement
as though the person complaining has the
right to a large captive audience and
one is a victim if people choose to tune
them out
odds are you're not actually canceled
you're just being challenged held
accountable or unliked
oh is that what the odds are is that the
odds are listen nobody
cares about being criticized more than
aoc and she claimed i was cat calling
her when i suggested that she come on my
sunday special
okay this is a person who really really
does not like criticism in any way
and i get a lot of criticism i don't
care i haven't been cancelled except on
college campuses where i was literally
cancelled from some college campuses
right that that's happened
that's cancelled culture people
attempting to to go after
advertisers or people attempting to to
go to corporate
to corporations to try and blacklist
people that that's cancelled culture
but people criticizing me is not
cancelled culture i've taken plenty of
it i'll take plenty more and
sometimes i deserve it but this notion
from the from people like aoc that
cancel culture purely does not exist
at a time when people are openly trying
to cancel people and ruin their
businesses and ruin their livelihoods
is pretty incredible she says i have an
entire tv network dedicated to soaking
hatred of me
a white supremacist with a popular
network show regularly distorts me in
dangerous ways and it's a normal part of
my existence to get death threats from
their audience you don't see me
complaining about canceled cultural
actually again you did like a year ago
she says many of the people actually
canceled are those long denied a fair
hearing of their ideas to begin with and
this is where we get into
it's not cancelled culture unless i
agree with the people who are being
canceled then it's cancelled cultured
so she says palestinian human rights
advocates have been canceled really have
they
have they now it seems like the entire
editorial board of the new york times
routinely amplifies the ideas of
so-called palestinian human rights
advocates
because the abolitionists have been
cancelled
abolitionists have been canceled i what
like of slavery
abolitionists have been canceled i feel
it's a pretty thorough going ideology in
the united states if you want to abolish
slavery
because anti-capitalists have been
cancelled no they just canceled
themselves because they couldn't
actually engage in the business world
and she's anti-imperialists have been
cancelled really anti-imperialists have
been cancelled
are you serious now because not spicy
contrarians want to play devil's
advocate with your basic rights
in the new york times okay if somebody
is if they have their editorials run and
then canceled
like pulled because their ideas are not
appropriate in new york times that is
the definition of a cancellation they
were literally canceled
but apparently canceled culture is good
with aoc she just re-characterizes this
the playing with words is pretty
incredible here
the left does it all the time cancel
culture is no longer cancelled culture
it's just accountability racism is no
longer racism
support of the system is racism the
linguistic tricks the left plays on a
routine basis
are really quite awful and the media go
along with them and
by the way the media loves this cancel
culture stuff because it allows them
to to play nightcrawler right no the
jake gyllenhaal movie
nightcrawler again i mentioned this on
the show it really is this
jake gyllenhaal plays a sociopathic
photographer who makes money
by freelancing he'll he'll hear a call
on the on the radio
if there's been a car crash he'll drive
over there he'll take pictures and sell
it to the local news and then he's
he realizes hey wait a second if i
actually stage this stuff i'm the first
person on scene
if i like kill somebody and then i take
pictures of it then i'm the first person
who can make money
off of that right well that's the media
when it comes to cancel culture so
they can the media will do things like a
battle tweet just resurfaced guys it's
like well how did it resurface
i stumbled on it while i was just
searching the advanced search function
on twitter for specific people to cancel
and then then what they do is they'll
say and you know what's even bigger news
i'm gonna call up
an advertiser on that person's show and
i'm gonna ask them whether they approve
of this that's not news
it's not news that people advertise on
shows they've been doing this to tucker
carlson for years
they've done this with me they do this
with everybody on the right that's not
news that's activism
if what you are doing is literally
indistinguishable from
from the from the sleeping giants or
media matters of the world then you're
just sleeping giants for media matters
and that's fine
but just to own it but the media won't
own it so instead you get articles
like this one from the washington post
about goya foods so goya foods
is a is a latino owned food company
which does enormous amounts of
charitable work in latin and south
america like enormous amounts of this
stuff
okay but oya food ceo robert eunanu
committed a sin evil sin
he stood alongside president trump he
said
we're all truly blessed at the same time
to have a leader like president trump
who's a builder that's what my
grandfather did
he came to this country to build to grow
to prosper so we have an incredible
builder we pray for our leadership
for our president we pray for our
country that we will continue to prosper
and to grow
terrible terror what was he there to do
by the way he was there to mark trump
signing an executive order
pledging to improve hispanic americans
access to educational and economic
opportunities
obviously a bad bad man very bad so aoc
tweeted oh look it's the sound of me
googling how to make your own adobo
because because now i'm not going to go
to goya anymore now i'm castro then
urged
castro urged julian castro urged
americans to quote think
twice before buying goya products if the
ceo praised trump
it is time to remove support from this
and
and the media just run with it the
washington post has a long article
about all of this by the way they employ
thousands of people worldwide
in past interviews members of the union
family have credited the brand's
authenticity for its popularity
but says the washington post maybe maybe
we should take a second look
we're just reporting guys we're just
reporting it is not worthy of a massive
report on goya foods when a few losers
on twitter decide that they are going to
boycott people that they don't like
again
if you think the goya is going under
because the ceo praised president trump
you're an idiot but apparently it's news
so long as the media make it news
this is the way the media push all this
stuff in the same way
that the media push the boycotts of
facebook in order to get facebook to
lower its standards for what constitutes
hate speech and therefore go after
people that the media don't like and
shut the doors
of the media to other actors in the
media as i mentioned yesterday
new york times spent tens of millions of
dollars every year on facebook marketing
its own material but they want to make
sure that facebook
cuts down the popularity of people that
they don't like
the the media's mail action here is it
continues to be the great story in the
the unraveling of america
because it turns out the people who are
supposed to translate the experts to you
are not translating they're just telling
you something different from what the
experts say it turns out the people
who are supposed to bring you objective
truth are giving you their truth it
turns out that the people
are supposed to be reporting on the news
are instead part of the news and making
the news it turns out that that's what a
lot of this is all about
and that's going to get better that's
going to get worse not better
unfortunately
again this is not the only example again
there's a there's a guy named thomas
bosco who owns the indian road cafe in
manhattan
he voted for president trump in 2016.
and now there are a bunch of people
who are who are trying to boycott him
and the media are covering it
right the new york times is covering it
it's not worthy of a media coverage
story when a few people tweet that they
don't want to eat at the local eatery
because the owner supported trump
that's just the media trying to pick a
message and then push the message
that's all that's happening here okay
meanwhile i'd be remiss if i did not
comment
on the supreme court ruling suggesting
that president trump has to turn over
his
tax records so the supreme court ruled
yesterday
that prosecutors in new york can see
president trump's financial records
the decision said he has no absolute
right to block release of the papers
now that that's not a shock i mean his
claim was over broad even clarence
thomas there's a 7-2 decision on this
one
because the claim trump was making was
overbroad he was basically saying
anything that could possibly
impact my performance as president under
any circumstances cannot be turned over
to a local prosecutor
and that's way too broad a case even
clarence thomas like that's way too
broad a case
thomas ruled that the problem was that
trump can then claim
that once that once the specific
subpoena is made for the tax records
that he was likely to win it so it
should be remanded back to the district
court and trump should do that we should
basically just dismiss the case
from cyrus vance but there's basically
unanimity on the court
that you don't that you can simply block
all access to paperwork because you're
the president of the united states chief
justice john roberts said no citizen not
even the president
is categorically above the common duty
to produce evidence when called upon in
a criminal proceeding
he said trump can still raise objections
to the scope and relevance of the
subpoena
so what does that mean well you know the
kind of going
notion is that trump lost the case and
it's really bad for him but not really
because this thing gets remanded back to
the lowest level and then trump can
simply say the subpoena is too broad
justice is clarence thomas and samuel
alito dissented president trump then
went after
the court right he said that the court
is really bad and really terrible listen
the court may be bad and terrible for a
variety of reasons but this is not one
of them
this ruling is actually not particularly
controversial and
the claims that were being made by
trump's lawyers were simply too broad
here's trump going after the supreme
court anyway
well the rulings were basically starting
all over again sending everything back
down to the lower courts and you start
all over again
so uh from a certain point um
satisfied from another point i'm not
satisfied because frankly
this is a political witch hunt alexa
which nobody's ever seen before it's a
pure witch hunt it's a hoax
it just continues it's been from before
i got here
when obama and biden and everybody else
was spying on my campaign
illegally okay the big problem for
president trump here is not the legal
problem he's not going to release his
tax returns before the election it's not
going to happen
okay but the big problem is now the
supreme court has said you kind of
should release your tax returns
that gives biden a club to hit him with
and there's been a lot of talk about by
not debating trump
until trump releases his tax returns now
the supreme court has said you should
probably release your tax returns or at
the very least
i mean they literally say this in the
decision they should probably release
the tax returns
because of that trump now has less of a
leg to stand on when he says i don't
want to release my tax returns and then
biden says
you're not obeying a supreme court
dictate now it isn't the supreme court
dictate but that's not how politics
works
and so it looks like trump is hiding
something obviously which is why the
white house didn't have great answers
when kaylee mcinanny was asked
isn't he kind of hiding something not
turning over his tax returns at this
point
the president can release his taxes
whenever he likes
so why shouldn't americans at this point
believe that the president isn't trying
to hide something
no the media has been asking this
question for four years and for four
years the president has said the same
thing
his taxes are under audit um and when
they're no longer under audit he will
release them
but i would also note the excruciating
ruling for house democrats who were
very much called out for their partisan
games they
also subpoenaed the president's uh
information financial information and
justice roberts said far
from accounting for separation of powers
concerns the houses approach aggravates
them
okay so there were two cases here one
was about whether congress
could grab records from presidents of
the united states that remains somewhat
controversial
so roberts basically said that the
courts have to perform a careful
analysis that takes adequate accounts of
the separation of power's principles at
stake
including both the significant
legislative interests of congress and
the unique position
of the president clarence thomas said
the congress does not have the ability
to just grab
private unofficial documents for any
random citizen that's not what congress
is there to do you can do this under the
impeachment power but you actually have
to do it
under the impeachment power the the one
about the d.a right which is cyrus vance
in new york who's
under attack from his left flank that
ruling basically said that cyrus vance
does have the ability to subpoena for
these records
he was joined in the majority by
ginsburg stephen breyer sonia sotomayor
and elena kagan
roberts dismissed the idea that the
stigma being subpoenaed will undermine
trump's leadership at home
and abroad and he pushed back against
the president's contention that having
to comply with the state criminal
subpoena would distract him from his job
as president according to scotus blog
which does good
analysis of these sorts of issues robert
stressed that the constitution does
allow such investigations
mere fact the president is served with
the subpoena is not likely to have much
of an effect on the president's
reputation roberts also declined to
adopt a rule suggested by the feds that
supported trump in this case that would
have required state grand jury subpoenas
for the president's private papers to
meet a higher standard demonstrating for
example
the evidence is critical that it cannot
wait until the end of a president's
term he said this would create a double
standard because federal subpoenas to
the president unlike state subpoenas
would be allowed whenever the evidence
is material
so roberts basically ended up sending
the case back to the lower courts and
trump can raise further arguments
challenging the subpoena in this case
as appropriate so you know the kavanaugh
voted with them
with the majority uh gorsuch voted with
the majority they both agreed that the
president is not absolutely immune from
state criminal subpoenas and that the
case should go back to the district
court they would require state
grand jury subpoenas like this one to
meet a higher standard that would
require a showing of demonstrated
specific
need clarence thomas descended he said
the president
isn't immune from the issuance of the
subpoena but that the president may be
entitled to relief from the enforcement
of subpoena and alito
also dissented in this case bottom line
here is that again it's more of a
political problem than a legal problem
for trump because by the time this whole
thing
works its way through the system it's
already july the election will have
already happened
by the time this goes back to a local
court and there's a big legal fight over
all of this
it's probably november december but all
it really does is it puts back on top of
the table why is trump hiding all this
information
it'll set the speculation going anew and
that is is not
a great shot so another hit for the
president politically even though it
really isn't that much of a hit
at him legally speaking all righty folks
well we have reached the end
of today's show but don't worry next
week there is much more show to come and
we'll recap everything for you plus make
sure you tune in
this sunday for the sunday special
compilation of the intellectual dark web
couldn't be more relevant today
go check it out on sunday you're
listening to the shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
colton haas executive producer jeremy
boring
supervising producer mathis glover and
robert sterling assistant director pablo
wydowski
technical producer austin stevens
playback and media operated by nick
sheehan
associate producer katie swinnerton
edited by adam sciovitz
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by nika geneva the ben shapiro
show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2020. you know the
matt wall show
it's not just another show about about
politics i think there are enough of
those
already out there we talk about culture
because culture drives
politics and it drives everything else
so my main focuses are
life family faith those are fundamental
and that's what this show is about i
hope you'll
give it a listen
you